[music]
>> Alhamdulillah.
Was-salatu was-salam ala Rasulillah wa
Amma ba'd. A'udhu billahi minash
shaytanir rajim.
Ud'u ila sabili rabbika bil-hikmati
wal-maw'izatil
Rabbi shrahli sadri wa yassirli amri
wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu qawli.
I welcome all of you
with the Islamic greetings, Assalamu
Alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
Now, we come to the last part of the
session
where inshallah we'll try and catch up
with both the things that have been
missed.
Number one
is the expectation
of
the international Dawah training program
of the participants, and second is the
introduction.
We have exactly
about 1 hour 45 minutes.
We can extend to 6:45 inshallah.
We'll try and cover the expectations
first and if time permits
we'll go to the introduction.
It was mentioned 2 weeks before
regarding the homework
and the expectations.
And there was email sent to all the
participants
that please mention the seven most
important expectations
that you have
from the international Dawah training
program.
And alhamdulillah
some of you gave expectations, some gave
less.
It was told to you and then you gave
more.
And some people even gave today evening.
Once you touch Bombay
except if you're living in Bombay.
If you're coming from abroad, we don't
expect the expectations to come after
14th of January.
Some people even heard my talk first
session, second session, and then saying
my expectation is about so and so what
I've already mentioned.
So this is
against
the benefit of this program.
Brother Kaleem shouldn't have taken it
in the first place.
The expectations are supposed to be
given to us before you leave your
country, before you leave your home, and
to reach us much before the 14th of
January. Anyhow, he has taken it and he
has merged. Many people discussed among
themselves and give it in the afternoon.
One person hasn't given so far. So I
said don't take it out, too late.
If you have not given your expectations,
you are the loser.
Normally what we do, if it comes in
time, we take out the common factor, so
we save time.
So if the expectations are overlapping
we overlap it without mentioning the
name and we said this expectation has
been said by
five out of the 19 participants.
Because some of them gave very late, we
could not merge and get the common
factor out. So we'll go through all the
expectations with the names, no problem,
and we'll try and finish inshallah in
next 1 hour.
What I told brother Kaleem that the
person who has given the shortest reply,
let his name be in the first.
Because sometimes the expectation is of
few words,
one sentence, some expectations and
paragraph. So, whoever has written more,
I've kept it in the ending.
So, at least we finish more number of
people in less time.
The shortest expectation according to
brother Kaleem,
shortest but not the worst, huh.
This brother Hashi Qureshi,
he gave seven. So, he's the lucky one
that his would be read first. Otherwise,
I said that has been answered earlier by
the other participant.
His first expectation
was to seek knowledge.
Has the answer been given?
Yes or no?
Yes, so your expectation now is
Uh bare minimum maybe ocean, that's a
different thing.
So, this
training program is not a
knowledge-based training program.
It's a technique-based training program.
So, if you have come here to gain
knowledge,
according to me,
it's not sufficient to be an
international guy this knowledge. Yeah,
we'll show you the technique.
But basic knowledge yes, it will cover.
Number two, to fulfill my obligation as
a Muslim
and be an effective guy.
Inshallah.
If you follow the three rules,
you will get this inshallah.
Expectation number three,
to learn from one of the best guys in
the world. The Allah will allow.
I don't consider myself to be the best
guy.
Yes, I'm a guy. I'm going to allow me to
accept our efforts.
And may Allah fulfill and may Allah
inshallah
through his mercy inshallah grant all of
us Jannah inshallah.
Number four, to interact with
Dawah participants from all over the
world.
Yes, inshallah. At least from 10
different countries.
And 10 important countries of the world
inshallah you'll be able to interact.
Expectation number five,
to enjoy while learning.
That depends upon you.
Enjoyment is subjective.
You know, many a times I do the things I
hate the most.
Many a time, or most of the times,
I do things which I hate the most, but I
enjoy. Why?
Because for the pleasure of Allah.
I personally don't like looking after
the technical aspects.
I hate it.
Administration aspect, oh, this stuff
has left. Oh, what to do? Okay,
overweight. Okay, camera is not working.
Sometimes ignorance is a bliss.
Or many a times, ignorance is a bliss.
Now, because
alhamdulillah, Allah has given me that
ability to grasp things fast.
Technically, alhamdulillah,
because of my expertise, they have to
refer to me. They're following the verse
of the Quran, "For solo Allah the decree
in good or ill I know." Ask the person
who is an expert. So, for them, they're
not bothered I'm expert like they think
I'm expert in technical things. There's
a saying that, you know, jack of all,
master of none. I say you can be jack of
all and master of many.
So, enjoyment is subjective.
I mean, I enjoy things I hate because I
do it for the pleasure of Allah.
Expectation number six,
to have a once-in-a-lifetime experience.
Inshallah.
Hope you feel it's a lifetime
experience. Some people think it's a
lifetime terror. You know, someone said
"It's a terrorizing."
Last time I remember one of the
participants said,
after 5-6 days,
"I see Dr. Zakir Naik even in my dreams.
When I sleep, I see him."
"Have I done my homework or not?"
Anyway, I don't take most of the
homework.
Hope it's a lifetime experience,
inshallah.
Expectation number seven,
and most importantly, to please Allah.
Inshallah, if your near is good
and intentions are clear,
Allah will be happy, inshallah.
Brother Kamruddin Abdullah,
to learn right methodology of Dawah to
various religious groups.
Inshallah.
This training would satisfy
most of the desires
as far as expectation number one is
concerned.
Technique of memorization.
Inshallah.
We'll start from tomorrow.
But again,
the key is
Allah's help.
Number two,
if you strive,
then technique will be helpful.
Otherwise, only technique it
will not be useful.
Number three,
able to answer tough questions.
You know, people ask me
that
which is the toughest question you have
ever faced?
So, I said this one.
So, now you know how to handle the
toughest question?
Brother,
do you know how to handle the toughest
question now?
Do you know or not?
Now you know, now? Correct.
So, I gave you the key in just one
sentence.
I mean, there have been many a time
where you realize that people ask
questions
and people always ask any question and I
always keep smiling and you know,
believe me, many a times I don't know
the answer.
By the time I come on the stage and I
keep smiling, brother asked a good
question and the answer comes from
Allah.
Allah helps you. So, if you have faith
in Allah, key is Allah's help.
Number four, able to debate.
Inshallah, that will cover
in the last
few days of the Dawah training program.
Number five, sharpness in public
speaking.
Inshallah.
Expectation number six,
taking Shahadah at the end of a lecture
or conversation. Inshallah, we are going
to have a day only. We have seen that in
the schedule. You wrote the expectation
before after? You wrote this today, no?
Masha Allah, no problem. Alhamdulillah,
good. You are a good guy, masha Allah.
Because there's a session
which was not there in the first two
phases.
It's mentioned in the 33 days program.
One day I've kept only for shahada.
So, insha Allah, that day is over, you
can
analyze whether you have learned it or
not.
Again, here also, most is Allah's help.
No one can give hidayah except Allah
subhana wa ta'ala.
It's Allah alone
who gives hidayah.
Point number seven,
learn management of an Islamic dawah
center. Though I've kept one day,
and I said that if I have to think
that if I have to share my experience
that Allah has
masha Allah blessed me with, it will
take at least 10 stages of dawah.
So, management itself would require more
than 15 days of rigorous training.
But we have kept one day.
In the first dawah training program, it
was only one session.
In this training program, we have kept
one full day,
insha Allah.
We go to the next participant, that's
Arshad Sagade.
Number one,
to become an effective da'ee.
Insha Allah.
To be able to answer challenging
questions and allegations on Islam.
Insha Allah, we'll be dealing with that.
To be able to defend Islam
and the Muslimin.
Yes.
Insha Allah, as far as defending Islam
is concerned,
as far as Muslimin is concerned, if he's
on the Quran and Sunnah, if he's a true
Muslim, then insha Allah we have to
defend him.
>> [clears throat]
>> To get confidence to speak in front of a
large gathering.
And I believe you have spoken in front
of a large gathering. But you are in a
large gathering.
He did mention, but didn't pay emphasis
on that. He's one of the students of the
Islamic International School.
There we train the children from the age
of
four
about public speaking skills.
Inna lillahi
>> [music]
[singing]
[music]